celui qui n'a pas eu descendance du tout
d'un seul coup il avait une fille et
quatre petits enfants et encore je vais
pas parler de mes petits-enfants à moi
et mon arrière petit-fils parce que là
ça aurait été vraiment le submerger
et nous accueillons notre terrien du
samedi 20h ce soir Françoise contrôle
alors Françoise vous êtes né après la
guerre d'une histoire d'amour éphémère
entre une Française et un soldat
américain cet homme votre père vous ne
l'avez jamais connu non mais il y a
quelques mois votre compagnon a retrouvé
sa trace il a 100 ans il vit dans une
maison de retraite à Los Angeles alors
le 26 mars dernier à l'âge de 68 ans
vous êtes allé embrasser votre père pour
la première fois c'est exact
nous raconterez votre histoire à 20h
[Musique]
Françoise contre rebonds le soir bonsoir
vous êtes né le 11 octobre 1945 à
Cherbourg mère secrétaire comptable dans
la marine et votre père sergent de
l'armée américaine venu libérer la
France il s'appelle Robert Joseph Garcia
alias le Sergent Garcia finalement
le problème c'est que votre naissance
votre père a déjà quitté la France et
vous allez grandir donc avec votre mère
votre grand frère et votre grande sœur
née d'un premier mariage de votre mère
alors durant votre enfance votre mère ne
vous cache pas la vérité non j'ai eu
cette chance là elle vous dit la vérité
elle vous dit comment la mort de son
mari quand la France a été occupée par
les Allemands elle est partie que ces
deux gosses se réfugier chez une amie à
Cherbourg qui posséder un hôtel
quand les Allemands finissent par se
rendre Cherbourg devient un port
important
deux fois plus importante New York à
l'époque et votre mère devient
secrétaire comptable à l'Arsenal tout à
fait
parallèlement elle continue à donner un
coup de main à l'ami qui l'avait
recueilli dans son hôtel oui pas très
longtemps et un jour alors qu'elle est
en train d'essuyer des verres derrière
le comptoir un soldat américain
s'approche et il lui dit laissez je vais
le faire il prend le torchon des mains
et c'était le début de leur idylle
inévitablement quelques mois plus tard
votre mère tombe enceinte
Garcia est au courant il est très
heureux de voir le ventre s'arrondir
dans tout le ventre il dit c'est mon
fils etc
mais en juin 1945 le g.i remonte sur son
bateau il rentre en Amérique sans
prévenir votre mère parce que c'est le
secret militaire
personne vous n'avez pas le droit de le
dire NON NON à ce moment là votre mère
Andrée est enceinte de 7 mois de vous et
vous naîtrez donc le 11 octobre 1945
alors de retour aux États-Unis votre
père charge sa soeur d'envoyer des colis
à votre mère
votre père enverra des colis pendant 7
ans oui mais alors se fera que deux au
départ parce que comme elle déménage une
colline ne sont jamais parvenus et puis
les gens les prennent parce que c'est
vrai qu'à l'époque de période de très
très difficile après la guerre Cherbourg
a été complètement détruite donc c'était
dur pour tout le monde en grandissant
donc vous cherchez à vous fabriquer une
image du père mais vous n'avez qu'une
seule photo en fait cette photo là je
vais regarder à la loupe j'ai essayé de
voir un petit peu accueillir santé
alors votre grand frère et votre grande
sœur vous parle de lui il était petit
oui
qui passe sur son bateau des choses à
profusion et en France les habitants de
Cherbourg Cherbourg ailleurs manquait de
tout quoi dire que vous en fait ça
augmente l'amour que vous avez pour
votre père parce que votre frère et
votre sœur vous dit c'est un mec super
voilà un moment aussi oui
alors le problème évidemment c'est que
vous saisissez très vite les différences
physiques entre vous vous avez un peu
l'air brésilienne disons voilà c'est ça
je suis vraiment le vrai d'un petit
canard surtout l'été l'été avec mes
cheveux frisés mais mais ma peau bronzée
à l'école on m'appelait la négresse
heureusement à l'adolescence cette
différence devient un avantage j'avais
quelques petits atouts qui plaisaient
bien quand même ça m'a ça marque inquiet
et puis il faut dire aussi la vérité
l'absence de votre père fait que vous
sortez vous dansez vous amusez quoi
j'ai un manque mais de l'autre côté bon
ça peut être aussi positif et votre mère
essaye de vous enfermer à clé dans la
chambre passer par la fenêtre
alors votre vie continue comme ça sans
savoir exactement qui est votre père En
fait lorsqu'il est devenu en tous les
cas c'est même pas si il est vivant
pas vous faites deux enfants avec le
premier homme de votre vie
ensuite il y a un deuxième homme de
votre Green et vous refaites encore deux
enfants mais c'est le troisième qui va
tout changer et oui le troisième il
s'appelle Yves Galles
et vous lui parlez de votre père dès le
premier rendez-vous parce que ça ça vous
obsède
j'étais plus fort que moi je savais que
j'explique que j'avais un père qui était
latino américain et que voilà et que je
lui ressembler beaucoup j'avais besoin
d'en parler alors là ce que fait Yves
c'est qu'il se plonge dans les archives
pour tenter de retrouver ce père disparu
pourquoi il a fait ça par amour puis
après c'est pris au jeu parce que
c'était une véritable passion et passer
c'est un vrai détective donc il a passé
des heures et des heures à rechercher à
recouper parce qu'en plus le patronyme
Garcia c'est un patron patronyme
extrêmement répandu il découvre qu'il y
a 40000 Robert Garcia et 100000 Garcia
voilà il s'est pas découragé quand même
c'est vraiment chercher une aiguille
dans une meule de foin là donc il est
passé
et puis un jour Yves retrouve cette
fameuse lettre de la sœur de Robert
Aline hein d'être là il y a une adresse
la maison de famille Albuquerque voilà
donc ça va être la base parce qu'il va
pouvoir faire des rapprochements avec
cette légion qui était dans l'armée
américaine
et là le 21 janvier dernier vous recevez
un courrier d'albuquer donc c'est un
cousin de votre père mais c'est le fils
d'Aline justement la sœur une des soeurs
préférées de mon père il avait vu sa
mère faire les colis pour l'enfant de de
Robert en France et voilà l'histoire
donc lui il a tout de suite su que
j'étais véritablement la fille de Robert
il l'a donc ce cousin vous écrit en
disant mais votre père est toujours
vivant il a 100 ans c'est extraordinaire
non et il vit dans une maison de
retraite à Los Angeles il se porte bien
pour un homme de 100 ans là quand vous
apprenez ça votre cœur manque de
s'arrêter là
bah oui c'est incroyable c'est une
histoire hallucinante parce que bon moi
j'arrive aussi à un âge avancé et mon
père a 100 ans est vivant et il a pas
Alzheimer il est pas grabataire enfin il
est je peux dialoguer avec lui voilà et
là en mars dernier vous voilà partir à
Los Angeles et oui
c'est la première fois que vous alliez
en Amérique ah oui j'avais jamais aux
États-Unis vous arrivez là-bas donc vous
allez dans la maison de retraite oui
alors il a fallu le préparer avant parce
que mon cousin Ernest lui avait dit
qu'on l'avait retrouvé en France que ça
file avait retrouvé et mon père avait
dit qu'il était extrêmement content
qu'on les retrouver extrêmement
satisfait mais
on lui a dit à la maison de retraite
qu'il fallait aller avec modération
parce que malgré tout bon pas trop
d'émotions pas savoir exactement comme
il pouvait réagir et ben finalement donc
on est arrivé Ernest est venu me
chercher mais c'était sauvé de sa
chambre parce que je pense que l'émotion
devait être un petit peu oui voilà et
donc il est passé dans le patio avec son
fauteuil roulant et d'un seul coup
Ernest me dit il est derrière toi
mais bon après ça c'est très bien passé
mon compagnon a eu aussi une idée de
génie c'est que
moi je suis j'adore les chats et mon
compagnon Yves donc lui a dit que
j'aimais beaucoup les chats et alors là
il m'a dit ah moi aussi et il m'a dit
attends je vais chercher mon album photo
alors dans son album photo bien entendu
il y avait les photos de sa femme parce
que c'est Maria 40 ans sans avoir
d'enfant parce que il a pas eu d'enfants
du tout je suis à sa fille unique
et les chercher son album photo et alors
là tout s'est très très belle voilà il y
avait des chats dans son album photo
c'était pour me montrer ces chats
alors durant ces quelques heures
finalement passées avec votre père
l'émotion est évidemment immense on s'en
doute mais il y a des moments marrants
c'est un homme qui avait beaucoup
d'humour d'ailleurs il est resté
espiègle
parce que il m'a parlé français il se
souvenait de quelques phrases en
français alors à ce moment-là votre père
donc prend votre main c'est une très
beau ce moment-là il apporte à sa bouche
et il vous garde comme ça pendant trois
quarts d'heure oui il m'a parution
jusqu'à mon départ n'a pas lâché la main
et lorsque mes enfants sont arrivés
parce que mes quatre enfants ont voulu
venir quand il les a vu
c'est vrai qu'ils sont ils sont très
typés ils sont ils sont beaux
mais il était là beautiful family parce
que lui qui n'a pas eu descendance du
tout la seule couille il avait une fille
et quatre petits enfants et encore je
vais pas parler de mes petits-enfants à
moi et mon arrière petit-fils parce que
là ça aurait été vraiment le submerger
vos origines en fait vous êtes d'une
famille andalouse émigré aux États-Unis
et vous avez du sang Navarro mon
arrière-grand-mère apparemment était une
Navarro d'ailleurs on est allé à Santa
Fe un petit peu faire un pèlerinage
là-bas conclusion merci
c'est mon héros j'ai deux héros
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu